[Música]
un cordial saludo y aquí comienza a ella
soy de france de 24 este programa lo
vamos a dedicar a los derechos de las
infancias trans mientras que méxico
ordenó proteger a los menores diversos
en eeuu hay disputas partidistas que
ponen en peligro su acceso a servicios
de salud física y mental para conocer
cada caso preparamos el siguiente
reporte veamos
un fallo histórico protegió las
infancias trans en méxico la suprema
corte de justicia declaró
inconstitucional la exigencia de tener
más de 18 años para solicitar un acta de
nacimiento que reconozca la identidad de
género de personas diversas la decisión
fue aprobada por unanimidad bajo el
argumento de que la norma vulnera el
derecho a la igualdad y no
discriminación hoy tenemos la
oportunidad de reafirmar con una sola
voz que no hay nada que curar de la
experiencia trans no es una enfermedad
sino una realidad que da cuenta de la
diversidad humana que las infancias y
adolescencias trans saben quiénes son y
comprenden su lugar en el mundo las
organizaciones de derechos humanos
celebraron los derechos de las infancias
diversas también son tema de discusión
en eeuu en texas hay una disputa en
tribunales después de que el gobernador
greg abbott ordenó a la agencia de
bienestar infantil investigar por abuso
a los padres que permitieran
de transición de género a sus hijos los
llamados procedimientos de cambio de
sexo constituyen abuso infantil bajo la
ley existente de texas debido a que el
departamento de familia y protección de
texas es responsable de proteger a los
niños contra el abuso por la presenta
ordenó a su agencia que lleve a cabo una
investigación pronta y exhaustiva de
cualquier instancia denunciada de estos
procedimientos abusivos el poder
judicial bloqueó temporalmente la orden
y la sociedad de endocrinología una
organización médica internacional dijo
que la directiva de abbott rechaza la
atención médica transgénero basada en la
evidencia la casa blanca rechazó la
retórica que se repite en varios estados
los estudiantes del egb
ya eran vulnerables al bullying ya la
violencia solo por ser ellos mismos esta
no es una acción aislada como lo
evidencian múltiples estados que están
haciendo esto hemos visto los
republicanos tomar acciones para regular
lo que los estudiantes pueden o no leer
lo que pueden o no aprender y lo más
preocupante que pueden o no ser el
senado de florida aprobó un proyecto que
prohíbe a los maestros hablar sobre
orientación sexual
de género en las aulas pero idaho
bloqueo una ley que habría prohibido la
atención médica de afirmación de género
para niños trans menores de 18 años en
2021 se firmaron 17 leyes estatales de
este tipo más que en los últimos 3 años
juntos según la organización human
rights campaign
para una conversación más profunda sobre
el tema están en ella soy tania morales
olivera activista y fundadora de la
asociación por las infancias de
transgénero que da acompañamiento a las
familias con niñas niños niñas y
adolescentes trance para el respeto a
sus derechos humanos y arianna lynch ha
sido y fundadora de arianna center una
organización que empodera y anima a la
comunidad trans del sur de la florida
con especial énfasis en los grupos
vulnerables bienvenidas ambas gracias
por estar con nosotros en ellas hoy y
empecemos con la buena noticia tania
porque este reconocimiento de mexico no
sólo protege a las infancias trans sino
que les ayuda en una construcción de una
identidad que ya es difícil sólo por
existir y que lo es mucho más cuando
somos seres diversos
si es que la mira durante muchos años
hemos estado tratando de avanzar
justamente el reconocimiento de la
identidad de género niñas niños y
adolescentes trans de méxico y los
países de latinoamérica son parte de un
sistema interamericano de derechos
humanos que desde 2017 dice que para
reconocer el género de una persona
se necesita únicamente un trámite
administrativo no patologizante que no
exijan y hormonas acciones ni
modificaciones corporales
y que además incluyen niñas niños y
adolescentes algo que es importantísimo
decir es que cuando hablamos del
reconocimiento de la identidad de género
de cualquier persona a cualquier edad
estamos hablando de documentos de
identidad cuando una persona puede tener
el caso mexicano un acta de nacimiento
que reconoce quién es su nombre y su
género pues la persona va a poder
acudir a un sistema educativo sin
discriminación libre de quienes va a
poder tener un pasaporte servicios de
salud etcétera y no tendría que estarlo
explicando a nadie ni quién es ni por
qué es de la manera que es y eso me
parece que nos parece que es muy
importante y es una lucha de muchos años
por la comunidad trans por las familias
en el hecho de reconocer a la persona
quienes desde el momento en que la
persona lo lo dice y esto también
permite un desarrollo libre s piense y
que ponga poco a poco su lugar en el
mundo y bueno pues en este caso fue
increíble porque bueno increíble no
maravilloso un conjunto de acciones que
se han hecho desde proponer legislación
es también amparos etcétera
hasta llegar a la suprema corte de
justicia en donde la suprema corte de
justicia dice que cada legislación
exista es totalmente en donde se indique
un procedimiento para poder tener un
acta de nacimiento primero reconocido y
nombre reconocido no puede excluir a
personas menores de 18 años y sí la
verdad que sí parece increíble pero
mientras tanto más increíble parece en
texas arianna es que el gobernador
republicano a voto haya ordenado
investigar a los padres que apoyan a sus
hijos en la construcción de esa
identidad se convirtieron los derechos
sexuales de las infancias trans en una
herramienta política para ganar votos
pues exactamente mira muchísimas gracias
por la pregunta angela y bueno pues esto
lo estamos viendo en todos los estados
que son republicanos y que anteriormente
pues con la anterior administración del
presidente trump se generaron estos
odios hacia grupos vulnerables verdad
como son los grupos la comunidad
transgénero a cabe resaltar que dentro
de la comunidad lgtb de la comunidad
transgénero estas más marginada y la que
menos servicios y apoyo recibe es la t
olvidada de las siglas lgtb what eso es
muy importante que no está nuestro
colectivo de personas transgénero nos
podamos reconocer y la infancia es algo
in
e imprescindible verdad no puedes hacer
a niños que crezcan con esa condición
comencé ese estigma de que el ser
transgénero es algo malo y eso no es
nada malo somos personas completamente
iguales a las demás simplemente que
pensamos y tenemos otra cosa diferente
la identidad de género para nosotros es
importante verdad entonces creo que
nosotros debemos ser tratadas con
respeto y específicamente los niños
verdad porque yo he sido niña y yo puedo
decir que soy el ejemplo de políticas
que hoy día el que con mis hijos no te
metas y grupos así de nuestros países
latinoamericanos que los por los cuales
yo tuve que huir de perú para poder
tener una vida libre y acá en eeuu y
trabajar por la comunidad de gvt por la
comunidad transgénero
nosotros estamos basados en la florida y
hemos tenido una ley también de donzell
gay
deja este verdaderamente el brecha de la
discriminación hacia nosotros las
personas transgénero y lo comporte bueno
arianna sobre eso le quería hablar y
pues además es que estos odios no son
nuevos van mucho más atrás en la
historia de estados unidos y del mundo
me atrevería a decir
estados como texas o florida e incluso
idaho y varios más han cruzado la línea
roja dando a la diversidad del
tratamiento en una retórica de
enfermedad mental eso hace parte de un
discurso que es ante todo
discriminatorio así que le pregunto
desde la base qué consecuencias trae
segregar y tratar como enfermo a un niño
o niña que ya de hecho tiene todos los
retos del mundo para acceder a su vida
diaria bajo estos parámetros de
autorreconocimiento
tiene pide acarrea muchos traumas a
correr a traumas en toda la vida una
persona que no es libre de expresarse en
la forma correcta de estudios y de i d
de superación y de encontrar la
personalidad va a ser muy difícil que
pueda trabajar y tener y enfrentar a la
vida yo creo que todos tenemos que
respetarnos y saber que todos somos
iguales que la infancia es es la parte
más bonita y que todos todos hemos sido
niños y que creo que no deberíamos en
lugar de apoyar de vivirlos apoyarlos a
que tengan mejor calidad de vida ya que
se enfrenten muchísimo mejor en la vida
verdad la vida es tan difícil para que
desde niños les den traumas de icod y
visiones como el estigma o el que es
malo el ser transgénero o es malo el
hablar de activo de tu sexualidad y por
eso estamos aquí para hablar de eso nos
quedan dos minutos de programa así que
muy rápidamente les voy a preguntar
tania por qué es indispensable que niños
niñas y niñas reciban atención médica de
afirmación de género y en qué consiste
bueno eso es este es un tema
distinto cuando hablamos en méxico al
menos estamos hablando no de un
tratamiento por supuesto no tiene que
ver con una cuestión médica a una niña
niño o niña lo único que se le permite
es vivirse libremente si la persona
decide ponerse una falta pantalón
quitarse un cabello o pintarse las uñas
eso es todo es una falacia el hecho de
que sea mitificada y se ha dicho que a
las niñas y niños y niñas trans del eso
pero se les hormonas eso es una mentira
absoluta eso no sucede
y entonces en realidad lo que se le
llama afirmación de género es sólo
respetar a la persona pues y como quiere
digamos crecer de manera libre eso es
todo hay muchos mitos alrededor de las
infancias trans y arianna para el cierre
muy rápidamente en su opinión sobre el
acceso a tratamientos cuando los niños
entran en la etapa de la adolescencia y
deciden que quieren hacer el cambio
mira angela yo te lo voy a decir de la
parte personal yo soy una persona
abiertamente viviendo con el virus del
vih y desde muy niña me habían dicho que
el ser transgénero es malo que era un
pecado o que yo podía cualquiera
de estas enfermedades que al final
cuando yo no pude ser mayor pude
identificar que no es un pecado que no
son personas que lo que les pasa es sino
porque la sociedad te obliga y te llega
a ese a ese aspecto soy yo he tratado de
luchar completamente con los con con los
talentos que dios me dio y que mi
familia me brindó en la educación para
poder romper esquemas en eeuu y trabajar
por la comunidad más vulnerada la
comunidad transgénero nosotros ya somos
una comunidad y merecemos respeto y por
eso simplemente queremos ser tratada con
personas transgénero y que nos valoren
nuestros talentos por nuestros talentos
no por lo que nos como somos o nos
identificamos pues muchísimas gracias a
ambas ha sido un verdadero placer para
mí recibir tanta información y tantas
aclaraciones de su parte y a nuestros
televidentes e recordarles ellas hoy es
un programa que habla derechos humanos
sigan con nosotros y nos vemos
próximamente en ella soy
[Música]